we're at a crossroads
a really critical phase in the pandemic
we're seeing a reduction in some of the
freedoms we've got and that is really
tough particularly young people
we've had weeks of warning but cases
have climbed
and now birmingham is under lockdown
from next tuesday there will be a
ban on households mixing so if you
live in one of those three boroughs you
cannot visit another household
and indeed you cannot host people from
anywhere
into your household the impact is huge
affecting birmingham the suburbs
solihull and sandwell
home to more than 1.6 million people
confirmed coronavirus cases in
birmingham have more than doubled
in the past week to 78 cases per 100
000 people if you don't follow these
rules that you've just heard loads about
already
then it will come it will come and visit
your family
you will know a family or a family
member or someone else very close
very shortly that will die
and i'm sorry if i'm blunt but i think
we need to be blunt
but however blunt it's still not getting
through
they're gonna make no difference because
everybody's getting together around here
there's no restrictions around here do
you walk down this street now you're
going to each shop
no one's waiting must no one's bothered
major hospitals in birmingham are
already back on high alert because of
the rising number of covert 19 cases
a number of schools have sent entire
year groups home because some students
have tested positive
this was meant to be the time things
were getting back to normal but it feels
like we're going back into another
crisis and enforcement
is harder than ever these are not
popular things
they're not rules everybody kind of is
wholly behind
people grudgingly now accepting we need
to follow the rules and that can create
some resistance for us of course finding
the time to make sure we do our normal
role
and this work is important so it
requires us to prioritize
and that's why i'm being very clear
we're going to be more targeted this
time
and for people like margaret with
underlying health conditions
there is a sense of frustration and fear
i can't be angry because some people
are not educated enough to understand
what this thing really is
what do you think people need to hear
them they're so hard-headed
if you even talk to them they don't
listen
watch closely what happens here because
if birmingham is at a dangerous
crossroads other towns
and cities may not be far behind
katrina for topsy sky news in birmingham